qu'est-ce que Tik Tok transmet aux
parties il faut en fait la question elle
est très vite
résolue une fois qu'on a compris que
aucune société chinoise ne peut tenir
tête aux parties c'est juste impossible
le système ne le permet pas d'abord
parce qu'aujourd'hui il y a une loi sur
le renseignement et une loi sur le
contrespionnage
donc de 2014 et de 2017 qui
autorise les services de renseignement
chinois a demandé à toute entreprise
chinoise de transmettre les données dont
elles dispose sur des individus ou des
personnes morales
mais soyons clairs les services de
renseignement chinois le faisaient déjà
avant que ces lois ne soient promulguées
et il ne viendra à l'esprit d'aucun
entrepreneur chinois qu'il s'agisse
d'une entreprise publique ou privée de
tenir tête au ministère de la Sécurité
d'État donc il faut partir de l'idée que
aucune entreprise
ne peut conserver des données
contre la volonté du du des services de
renseignement chinois qu'il s'agisse du
ministère de Sécurité d'État ou du
ministère de la Sécurité publique
cela étant dit
les données dont on parle sont une
goutte d'eau dans l'océan des données
captées par la Chine ça il faut aussi en
avoir conscience c'est à dire que c'est
c'est louable de s'attaquer à la
question des données que TikTok peut
collecter mais ça ne représente qu'un
très faible pourcentage de la masse de
données captées par la Chine aujourd'hui
si on parle serait ce que des États-Unis
qui est l'acteur le plus impliqué dans
cette opposition à Tik Tok aujourd'hui
les opérations cyber menées contre
l'office du management du personnel
américain ou
l'entreprise Equifax donc qui est une
société de de
régulation des du crédit à la
consommation à offert et on pourrait
ajouter le l'opération de hacking des
données de la chaîne total Marriott
avec ces trois opérations cyber la Chine
détient des millions de données sur des
individus américains sur à peu près la
moitié de la population américaine
ce qui est beaucoup plus large et des
données beaucoup plus précises puisque
c'est aussi des données financières
c'est des données sur qui a fait une
demande
de d'habilitation au secret défense aux
États-Unis voilà donc des données
beaucoup plus précieuses pour les
services chinois que celles offerte par
Tik Tok donc je vais en train de dire
bien sûr que c'est pas important qu'il
faut pas s'en occuper mais c'est qu'une
toute petite part des données qui sont
captées par par la Chine aujourd'hui